you need to look a certain way you need
to look glad this is very much pressure
Kate's a 20 year old student who's
funding her way through university by
dating older men
she's a so-called sugar baby it's saved
quite a lot pays for my travel my books
I haven't had to take out a student loan
I've been quite well-off she earns two
thousand pounds a month from her
relationship with an older man who she
met online
she'll come to an arrangement and then
Deputy financial help in there that this
meeting to say there be Assembly meets
per week and he said intimacy oh yeah if
sex part of the equation
oh yeah of course I mean there's a very
fine line between prostitution and being
a sugar baby students are so valuable
because it's just quick money they need
money
one of the biggest websites told us 50%
of its sugar babies in the UK are
students and there are 12 times more
students on the site and in 2009 of
those they claimed 12,600 have submitted
pre to the university enrollment the
site's founder says he's just running a
dating web site with financial perks
it's sort of the business dream so to
say the disney dream it sounds a lot to
me like an escort service it's the
romantic fairy tale their appetizing
enroll is sugar baby university today
and get your education
by generous mods on the site I'm 52 in
real life I'm 62 in married for 35 years
I've got four children and now I've got
four sugar babies sugar daddy Adam is
one of those sponsors the really good
thing about being a sugar daddy is that
it enables you to punch above your
weight sex is an integral part of the
site trotting it all up I probably spent
twenty to thirty thousand pounds and
Adam believes he's not the only one
benefiting I think it's really
appropriate for students if they're
happy to go out with older men then what
a great way to get a little bit of extra
pocket money and much better than having
to spend eight hours slogging away in a
bar
earning the minimum wage of course no
father would recommend that daughter's
choice I'd like this but more and more
students are dating their way out of
debt and finding their education has
come at a price Sarah had to be Gary Sky
News